-Welcome back. We have such
a great show for you tonight.
You know what? Before we go on,
I'm a little hungry.
So if you don't mind, I'm going
to grab something right now
from the "Tonight Show" freezer
really quick.
It'll only take a second.
Sorry about that.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Freezer Secrets."
[ Thud]
-No!
Help! I'm stuck!
I'm stuck in the freezer!
-There's no use.
-Will Forte?
[ Cheers and applause ]
What are you doing here?
-Well, I thought this was
the bathroom.
And I didn't realize it wasn't
until I tried to leave.
-This is awful.
I knew it was a mistake buying
a soundproof freezer.
We're doomed.
-Yeah.
Well, since this is the end,
I have a few secrets I need to
get off my chest.
-Same.
One time, I finished
a box of cereal
and put the empty box
back in the cupboard.
[ Laughter ]
-I did something similar once.
-Really?
-Yeah.
You know the Trivago guy?
-Sure.
-Well, back in 2004, me and him
got away with
vehicular manslaughter.
[ Laughter ]
-Will, that's way worse
than what I said.
-Tomato, tomahto.
[ Laughter ]
-Tonight, during our interview,
I was going to mention how much
I love "MacGruber,"
but I've never seen it.
[ Laughter ]
-To be fair, I've never seen
"The Tonight Show."
[ Laughter ]
The only show I watch is --
-"Cocomelon."
[ Laughter ]
-Whenever I go to Chipotle,
I fill my water cup with soda.
[ Laughter ]
-Whenever I go to Chipotle,
I fill my soda cup with water.
-Why?
-I'm not like the other girls.
[ Laughter ]
-I still don't understand
how NFTs work.
-NFTs don't work.
That's the whole point.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, what do you think NFT
stands for?
-Nonfunctioning testicle.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I have two of them.
[ Laughter ]
-When we were on "SNL" together,
I thought you were an intern.
[ Laughter ]
I asked you to get me coffee
multiple times.
-I spit in that coffee
every time.
[ Laughter ]
And not just a normal amount.
I filled that puppy to the brim.
It was all spit, no coffee.
[ Laughter ]
I watched you drink it
and you'd say,
"This is the best coffee
I've ever had.
Please get me another one."
That's what you sound like.
-It really was good coffee.
-Yeah.
Hey, remember when people were
mailing anthrax to 30 Rock?
-That was you?
-No. It was Rachel Dratch.
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
My real name isn't Jimmy Fallon.
It's Stanley Tucci.
It was already taken,
so I had to change my name.
-My real name isn't Will Forte.
It's Gwyneth Paltrow.
[ Laughter ]
And I had the idea for Goop.
Not her.
-Gwyneth?
Wait, I should not leave my mask
on.
-Yeah, you should probably --
[ Laughter and applause ]
We'll be back.
-Start it over, right?
-The whole sketch.
Start the whole sketch over.
-Start again. Ready?
-Who goes there?
Should I do the "my real name
isn't Will Forte"?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-In 3, 2...
[ Thud ]
-My r--
-I--
[ Laughter ]
Aren't you guys freezing?
-Should we recast this?
[ Laughter ]
-One more -- One more time.
-I'm doing the Gwyneth Paltrow
line again.
-Oh, you're going to say
the line.
-Yeah, he's going to say
-Okay.
-Smoke in this freezer.
-My real name isn't Will Forte.
It's Gwyneth Paltrow.
And I had the idea for Goop.
Not her.
-Gwyneth? Tucci?
You guys freezing?
-Not anymore.
I mean, our happiness and our
friendship has defrosted us.
We're saved!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Clicking ]
-Wait.
Do you hear that?
-Oh, it's nothing. Just my NFTs.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's go! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This has been
"Freezer Secrets."
Stick around for more
"Tonight Show" after the break.